Merhabalar Ben İpek ağacı sizlerle bugün
renkli bir yolculuğa çıkacağız Evet
renkli beslenmenin öneminden
hayatımızdaki etkilerinden size
bahsetmek istiyorum
bakın yolculuk öncesinde önce ben kendi
yolculuğumun hikayesinden size biraz
bahsedeceğim
benim Çocukluğum hastane odalarında
muayenehane odalarında doktorlarla
birlikte geçti annem bir diş
hekimliğiydi
Mesleğimi çok severdi ve tutkuyla
yapardı Sabahın erken saatlerinde
hastanesine gider yoğun bir şekilde
çalışmalarına öğleden sonra
muayenehanesinde vardı
kardeşim ve benle daha fazla vakit
geçirmek için de muayenehanesinin arka
odasına bir çocuk odası
yapmıştım bu çocuk odasında kimi zaman
Gündüz uykusu yapar kimi zaman
bahçesindeki meyve ağaçlarından meyve
[ __ ] kimi zamanda annemin asistanı
yani
rahatsızlandığında ona yardım ederdik
çok da hastanede hastası olduğunda
beni çok severdin
dinamik ortamı ve sanki kendimi film
izliyormuşçasına oturup baktığımda
gerçekten çok güvenirim ve en büyük
hayalim bir hastanede çalışmaktı
ve aradan yıllar geçti artık
Üniversiteye giriş zamanı gelmişti bu
adamı pek de fena değildi önünde sonsuz
olasılıklar vardı babam kendisi gibi
Mimar olmamı istiyordu Fakat benim
hayallerim çok daha farklıydı beslenme
diyetetik okumak istiyordum
bu fikri mi çevremdeki birçok kişiyle
paylaştım Çok da fazla destek aldım
söylemez
bilmiyorum Annemin bir doktor arkadaşı
bir akşam tam da tercih zamanında beni
aradı dedi ki ipekciğim sen diyetisyen
olunca mutlu olmazsın gel boş ver vazgeç
ama ben vazgeçmedim Çünkü gerçekten
diyetisyen olmayı çok istiyordum ilk ve
tek tercih olarak Hacettepe
Üniversitesi'nde beslenme
üniversitede eğitimime devam ettim
birçok hastane çalıştım birçok kurumda
çalıştım birçok doktorla çalıştım ve
mesleğime hep çok sevdim hep çok severek
yaptım hiç pişman olmadım ve ekip
çalışmasını da çok inanan birisiyim her
zaman için ekip çalışması içerisinde
Mesleğimi çok severek yaptım ve aradan
koskoca bir video geçti oldukça yoğun
bir işlem fon vardı hastanelerde çok
yoğun çalışma tempolarım oldu artık son
yıl dedim ki İpek biraz yavaşlaman lazım
ve kendine vakit ayırman
Evet çalıştığım hastanede kendi işimi
kurmak adına istifa ettim bir isim
koymalıydım bu ne olmalıydı renkleri çok
seviyorum ve renklerin gücüne gerçekten
çok inanıyordum Benimki diyet niye
olmasındı ve 7 yıl önce 1 Şubat sabahı
renkli diyet kuruldu
Belki bir logo yaptırdım renkli bir
tabela yaptırdım ve ilk O kısmı açtım ve
artık yoğun iş temposundan dolayı
beklettiğim iki hayalimde
gerçekleştirmenin tam zamanıydı birisi
Anne olmak değil ise kitap yazmaktı
hamileyken işte Bunu yazdım ve böylece
iki hayalimi birden gerçekleştirmiş
oldum oğlum özgür dünya ile işte bunu da
okuyucularla buluştu
Tum ya bu renkli diyet
ve gerçekten Bizim psikolojimiz üzerinde
olan etkilerine hepimiz yanıyoruz
hepimiz renkleri çok severiz Örneğin
günlerimiz daha renkli geçsin diye
uğraşıyoruz hayatımıza renklendirmeye
çalışıyoruz Aslında bu durum beslenmemiz
için de çok geçerli Yani biz
beslenmemizde ne kadar
iyiyse hayatımızda o kadar renkli
olduğunu sağlığınızda o kadar renkli
olur bu yüzden beslenmemizi
renklendirmeliyiz
Aslında sağlıklı beslenmenin En renkli
halidir
Evet Gökkuşağında 7 tane renk var renkli
diyetimizde ise 5 tane renk var peki
nedir bu renkler kırmızı mor beyaz
turuncu ve yeşil
sebzeler nasıl bu renkleri alıyorlar
içerisindeki pigmentlerden dolayı
alıyorlar şimdi çok daha ayrıntılı
bahsetmek istiyorum sizlere enerjimi
renge kırmızıyla başlayalım Ben de bugün
kırmızı giydim kırmızıyı gerçekten çok
seviyorum kırmızı renkli meyve
sebzelerde içerisinde bulunan mikopen
adlı bir madde var ve likopen aklın
vakti çok güçlü bir antioksidan ve bu
meyve sebzeleri rengini veren
antioksidan birçok çalışmada özellikle
bir köpeğinin kansere karşı koruyucu
olduğunu bize gösteriyor
bu kırmızı meyve sebzeler çilek domates
kuşburnu karpuz listede görüyorsunuz tüm
gördüğümüz kırmızı meyve sebzeler Her
gün en az bir avuç kadar beslenmemize
mutlaka olmalı
tüm yeşillerde beslenmemizde olması
gereken renklerden biri her gün mutlaka
bir avuç kadar tüketmeliyiz ve sonra
rengimiz beyaz top Pardon mor sondan bir
öncekinin rengimiz mor da
güzelliğinle asaletin rengi Evet mor
meyve sebzeleri gördüğümüzde onları
gençlik iksiri olarak
değerlendirebiliriz
çünkü hem de bu mor rengi veren bir Mert
ve gençlik güzellik kendimizi iyi
hissetmek üzerinde oldukça etkili
patlıcan mor erik mor lahana kırmızı
soğan bütün gördüğünüz yeşil ve Kiraz
gibi morlarda beslenmemizin en önemli
renklerinden
ve son rengimiz beyaz temizliğin
arınmanın detoksu rengi Tam da vücudumuz
içinde Aslında bu şekilde beyaz renkteki
meyve sebzeler içerisindeki
antioksantinden dolayı bu renge sahipler
ve vücudumuzun temizlenmesinde etkiler
ve sindirim sistemi dostu olarak da
düşünebiliriz elma muz Armut ayva
enginar lahana gibi birçok beyaz meyve
sebzede her gün bir avuç kadar mutlaka
beslenmenizde yerini almalı Peki renkli
beslenmek sadece meyve seti tüketmek
midir Tabii ki hayır bu yeterli beslenme
olarak geçmeyecektir Evet meyve
sebzeleri Biz tüketiyoruz renkli
beslendiğimizde renkli diyeti
yaptığımızda ama bunu ek olarak
öğünlerde et grubu besinler süt grubu
besinler ve ekmek grubu besinler de
mutlaka ihtiyacımız kadar menülerimizde
yerini almalı
Her zaman söylediğim gibi renkli
beslendiğimizde yaşamınızın da
renklendiğini göreceksiniz Bu gerçekten
böyle demişsiniz beslenen bir kişi iç
organlarını hayatını sağlığında renksiz
hale getirecektir hem ruh sağlığınız
için özellikle de pandemide çok daha
fazla ihtiyacımız var
engelli beslenmeye Özen gösterin
sizlere Bir örnek üzerinden devam etmek
istiyorum sizlere bir kişiyle
tanıştırmak istiyorum Belki de siz çok
iyi tanıyorsunuz zaten bu kişiyim ismi
Irmak 34 yaşında İstanbulda yaşıyor çok
yoğun çalışan bir bankacı
Irmak Yaklaşık 4 yıl önce birlikte
çalıştığımız ve bana başvuran rengarenk
danışanlarımdan biri
ırmağın Aslında kilosu ve boyu Gayet iyi
yani vücut ölçüleri birçok kadının
hayalindeki gibi
yoksa 60 kilo boyu 1,70 gayet iyi Fakat
ırmağım dışında Aslında dışarıdan Çok
sağlıklı gözükürken
pek de her şey yolunda değil
tık daha iyi tanıdığımda Gerçekten bu
durumu böyle olduğunu zaten görüyorum
bir kabızlık şikayeti var bağırsakları
çalışmıyor
artık hasta oluyor Bütün kışı Grip ile
geçiriyor Ve tabii ki bahar aylarında da
alerjim ve ruh hali çok değişken çok
zaman daha depresif olabiliyor kendisini
mutsuz hissedebiliyor her danışanımdan
olduğu gibi
beslenme gününü istedim ve Bir hafta
boyunca yediklerini içtiklerine bir
kağıda yazmasını istedim
sağlıksız besinler tüketmiyordu
miktarlarda Fena değildi Çok ilginç
söylenemez fakat menülerinde çok önemli
bir şey eksikti O da Renkler çok renksiz
besleniyordu
Şimdi sizlerle paylaşmak istiyorum
ve Şimdi sizlere göstermek istiyorum
menü 2 ise bizim beraber
ırmakla birlikte renklendirdiğimiz menü
kahvaltıdan Beyaz peynirli Bir sandviç
çay içtiğini söylemiş
yıllık ezmesi tükettiğini yazmış
kahvaltı çok renksizdi dolayısıyla çok
az miktarda posa ve lif vardı Bunun
içerisine sandviç içine kırmızı ve
yeşili kaptım domates ve nane olarak
yanına Salatalık ve kırmızı ile domates
ekledim ve fındık ezmesine de vişne
reçeli yaptım yani mor
iki çay içtiğini söylemiş bitki çayının
yanına 3 tane kuru kayısı koydum Böylece
turuncuyla Ara öğünde renklendirmiş
oldum Evet Öğle yemeğinde Peki neymiş
kuru fasulye pilav ve yoğurt yediriyor
aldık Aslında miktarlar oldukça uygun
ama çok renksiz bir tabak yoğurducacık
yaptım yani yeşillendirdim ve yanına
rengarenk güzel bir çok az salatası
koydum Peki ara ödeme yaptım 6 tane
birisini getirdim
3 karisiyle indirdim ve yanında yarım de
yani kırmızı etle ara evlendim
ve Akşam yemeğimiz bam Buğday ve esmer
ekmek yediğimi yazmış ve somon tüketmiş
yanında Peki ben de yaptığım akşam
yemeğindeki bu güzel meyveye mor turuncu
yeşil renkte rengarenk güzel bir salata
koydum haşlanmış soğanlar ve
sarımsakları ilave ettim yani Beyaz da
koydum ve yine brokoliyi de yeşillere
destekledim ve Gece Son ara yönünde 20
tane badem yanında elma tükettiğini
söylemiş Ortalama bir avuç kadar bademle
ben bademin miktarını indirdim ve bir
tane kivi ekledim
Niçin bu renkler var Evet amacım
enerjisini çok da değiştirmeden memnun
daha çok renklendirmekti bunu da
başardım Aslında
baktığımızda 2 milimin neredeyse
enerjinin aynı şekilde protein
miktarları da aynı herhangi bir kayıp
söz konusu olmadı fakat mid'e
baktığımızda menünün lif oranı bir buçuk
kat daha fazla arttı özellikle kabızlık
yaşayan Irmak Belki de artık kabızlık
yaşamayacaktı ve bağırsakları çok daha
iyi çalışacaksın
Evet devam edelim vitamin ağ değerlerini
hesapladım ve menü diyelim m2 arasında
çok ciddi bir vitamin ağ değeri var tam
3 kat daha fazla vitamin a olacak artık
Irmak yeni menüyle ve aynı şekilde 7 kat
daha fazla karoten alacak evet özellikle
bağışıklık sistemi üzerinde bu
turuncular A vitamini karatenden
bahsetmiştik artık Irmak çok daha az
hastalanacak Belki de Çünkü bağışıklık
sistemi çok daha güçlü olacak
Irmak özellikle hamile kalmak isteyen
bir bayandı Bu yüzden de folik asit
alımı çok önemliydi Evet Irmak artı
renklendirilmiş menüyle Tam iki kat daha
fazla folik asit alacak Ve böylelikle
Belki de daha sağlıklı bir gebelikle
birlikte daha sağlıklı bir süreç
geçirmiş olacak ve son olarak C vitamini
Peki ne kadar C vitamini artmış olabilir
10 kat daha fazla artık C vitamini alır
hale geldi
Irmak Bu da şu demek her hastalıklara
karşı daha koruyucu bağışıklık sistemi
çok daha güçlü ya da kendini daha iyi
hissedecek Evet korkak daha fazla artık
C vitamini almış olacak
ve potasyum değerine hesapladım 2 kat
daha fazla potasyum alacak Bu da şu
demek artık hipertansiyon çok daha az
her hastalıkta riski de çok daha az ve
son olarak
likopen tam da bugünün rengi 10 kat daha
fazla artık likopen alacak koyduğumuz
domateslerle greyfurtlarla ve 10 kat
daha fazla nikotenlemek
ırmağın kansere yakalanma riskinin çok
daha düştüğü anlamına gelebilir işte Tam
da bu yüzden renkli
beslenmek istiyorum
Evet ben de 14 yıldır nice ırmaklarla
çalıştım
belki anneniz
kardeşiniz veya eşiniz Evet
Irmaklar Aslında sağlıklı beslendiğimi
düşünebiliyor ama biraz renkli
beslenebiliyorlar
çok Danış hanımın hep beslenmesini
renklendirdim ve hala daha çalıştığım
şirketlerde okullarda çocukların
yetişkinlerin Hatta dünyanın birçok
yerinde yaşayan kişilerle irtibata geçip
onlara beslenme danışmanları vererek
hayatlarını ve sağlıklarını
renklendirmeyi amaçlıyorum
Ben tabii ki varlar Çok teşekkür ederim
renkli ve sağlıklı günler